[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 9 janvier les
titres de cette édition
trente sixième jour de grève contre la
réforme des retraites ce jeudi les
syndicats appelaient à une nouvelle
mobilisation interprofessionnelle et
nous étions au départ du bus de l'aef et
suivent ligne vers la capitale pour
participer au cortège parisien une
nouvelle action en justice de cette
association fin décembre elles ont porté
plainte contre x avec constitution de
partie civile le but l'ouverture d'une
instruction judiciaire suite à la fuite
d'hydrocarbures survenue en février
dernier dans le département
enfin les municipales 2020 à la tête de
la verrière depuis 2016 nelly duthu sera
candidate pour un nouveau mandat la
maire sortante communiste mènera la
liste la verrière en commun et puis on
parlera aussi du scrutin à montigny le
bretonneux avec le lancement officiel
d'une première candidature pour prendre
la suite de jean luc ourgaud nouvelle
journée de grève et de mobilisation
aujourd'hui contre la réforme des
retraites il s'agit de la quatrième
mobilisation interprofessionnelle depuis
le début du mouvement à paris à 370000
personnes ont défilé dans le cortège
selon la cgt et dans le cortège
justement des enseignants des yvelines
plusieurs bus avaient été affrétés au
départ de notre département depuis plus
d'un mois ils sont mobilisés à trappes
ils étaient une vingtaine à partir en
fin de matinée vers la capitale et
propos sont recueillis par aurélie rose
et rémi lefebvre là c'est un temps fort
pour exprimer
ce qui est inacceptable c'est à dire
cette réforme des retraites à points
cette retraite n'a qu'une seule vocation
c'est de diminuer ce qu'on appelle le
taux de remplacement qui passerait de 70
à 50 % pour l'ensemble des salariés et
qui pénaliserait particulièrement les
enseignants en ce qui nous concerne que
la solidarité est cassée elle est cassée
entre les générations entre les hommes
et les femmes entre ceux qui gagnent
beaucoup et ceux qui gagnent peu et ce
sera une régression sociale pour 99 %
des salariés comme ça s'est passé en
allemagne et en suède où la retraite par
points a été mise en place mais la grève
qui continue de créer des perturbations
des écoles yvelinoise quelque peu
impacté aujourd'hui dans les transports
beaucoup de perturbations et depuis le
début du mouvement en conséquence le
pass navigo du mois de décembre sera
entièrement remboursé annoncé hier soir
de la présidente de la région ile de
france valérie pécresse gain de cause
obtenu après des négociations avec la
ratp la sncf 200 millions d'euros seront
à débourser pour se faire dédommager une
plateforme internet sera accessible
avant la fin janvier
il suffira de vous munir de votre
justificatif de paiement ou du numéro de
votre pass navigo et de le renseigner
sur le site lors de votre demande
mais vous le savez un les perturbations
vont se poursuivre dans les prochains
jours vos prévisions de circulation pour
la journée de demain vendredi à
retrouver sur les sites de la ratp et de
transilien
une cérémonie des voeux de 2020 à
plaisir sur fond de paris nice hier
mercredi au gymnase nicholas l'air la
mère joséphine coleman ce berger a
rappelé que sa commune sera la ville
départ de la course cycliste le 8 mars
prochain
elle est ensuite revenue sur les
événements marquants de l'année 2019 en
justifiant l'importance des maires et
des communes dans la société actuelle
les propos sont collectées par nicolas
landry
c'est s'oublier et c'est être avec mes
autres hommes
c'est à dire d'avoir une disponibilité
grande d'avoir le sens des
responsabilité d'être à l'écouté
même quand les choses sont difficiles
parce qu'aujourd'hui la population est
vraiment dans une morosité forte et je
pense que le maire est encore l'entité
qui est ancré sur le territoire vers qui
on peut se tourner frapper à la porte
dire madame le maire ça madame le maire
ça ne va pas et ça je crois qu'il faut
qu'on le garde précieusement
souvenez vous cette catastrophe remonte
au 24 février dernier la rupture du
pipeline d'ile-de-france de total à
hauteur d'eau tout y est vic et boissy
sans avoir les résultats 1 millions de
litres de pétrole déversés dans des
champs et cours d'eau fin décembre cette
association ont porté plainte contre x
avec constitution de partie civile pour
pollution des eaux de sont en plateau
avec nous france nature environnement
yvin représenté par marie josé rossi
jaouen est souvent les yvelines avec
philippe fortement bonsoir à vous deux
et vous êtes venu accompagné de votre
avocat marc pittie ferrandi bonsoir
poussins vous êtes avocat au barreau de
paris et vous exercer sur le droit
public et le droit de l'environnement
déjà pourquoi cette nouvelle action en
justice on rappelle qu'il avait déjà une
plainte qui avait été déposée sur ce
sujet bien pas parce que quand on dépose
plainte
on dépose plainte contre x auprès de
madame la procureure de la république de
versailles
madame la procureure a tout le loisir de
donner suite ou non à cette plainte
donc nous avons fait cette plainte au
mois de décembre
au mois de décembre et puis donc pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas eu de réponse
donc la seule façon que nous avons de
pouvoir porter l affaire en justice ces
deux grosses de se constituer partie
civile et a procuré un juge
d'instruction va être nommé et à ce
moment là nous pourrons avoir accès au
dossier cas actuellement jusque depuis
le début de cette affaire
nous n'avons jamais eu accès au dossier
c'est-à-dire dénoncé aujourd'hui un
manque de transparence sur le dossier
un manque de transparence voire même
fois un peu de mépris à la gare des
associations de protection de
l'environnement alors que notre démarche
elle se veut
sereine elle se veut responsable nous ce
que nous voulons c'est savoir ce qui
s'est passé
comprendre pour éviter que ça se
reproduise et surtout prendre des
mesures nécessaires pour protéger
l'environnement dans les années à venir
le 'pipeline' a été remise en service
depuis juillet il relie pour rappel la
raffinerie de grandpuits en
seine-et-marne et le dépôt pétrolier du
havre
marie josé rossi jaouen quel est le
travail qui a été mené par les
associations justement sur ce dossier
depuis un moment et bien les
associations d'abord participé à toutes
les réunions organisées par les
préfectures de façon à montrer qu'elle
était vigilante sur l'évolution du
dossier nous avons demandé à plusieurs
reprises la communication de documents
en particulier sur l'analyse du tronçon
qui avait été impacté par cette fissure
nous avons aussi qu'on s'appelle
travaillé sur le projet d'arrêté quant à
la remise en état de la parcelle qui
nous semblaient dans son premier jet
dix ont présenté un certain nombre de
manques nous attendons toujours un
arrêté sur les conséquences sur le
milieu qui est très clair que jean n'a
pas de vision sur les conséquences vous
redoutez qu'est ce que vous redoutez
justement une pollution considérable et
bien effectivement sur la pollution de
l'eau il nous manque encore un certain
nombre d'éléments sur les conséquences
sur la faune et la flore
il n'y a pas eu vraiment de bilan de
fait les associations plus spécialisés
ou en quelques résultats sur les
conséquences sur les assets les
batraciens et cetera mais on n'a pas un
bilan encore bien défini nous avons des
inquiétudes aussi en ce qui concerne l'
infiltration donc des hydrocarbures en
direction des nappes phréatiques puisque
il était prévu un délai de 100 jours
et visiblement les travaux n'ont pas été
effectués dans sa de vision finalement
sur les conséquences alors je précise
que le groupe total que nous avons
sollicités à n'a pas pour le moment
répondu à nos sollicitations marc pittie
ferrandi je me tourne vers vous ce qui
nous reste peu de temps dans cette rampe
entretien expliquez-nous la
particularité de cette action donc c'est
une plainte contre x avec constitution
de partie civile qu'est ce que qu'est ce
que ça signifie
ça signifie qu'on ne demandent qu'un
juge d'instruction soit nommé il faut
savoir que cette pollution 2019
elle fait suite à une précédente
pollution 2014 cinq ans avant avant
celle ci et qui était une policiers à
peu près 500 mètres cubes de pétrole
dont les causes n'ont pas été élucidées
puisque justement il n'y avait pas eu de
juge d'instruction il ya une plainte qui
a été déposée par une association de
protection de l'environnement qui
aboutit à un classement sans suite c'est
ça qu'on veut éviter ici on veut qu'un
juge d'instruction rend dans le dossier
fouilles met en évidence les négligences
et on a persuadé qu'y en a c'est une
évidence finalement le simple fait que
la pollution se répète cinq ans après et
que l'on n'ait pas attiré les clairement
les conclusions de deux des causes de la
pollution 2014 sans nous plus
d'identifier réellement les causes de la
pollution 2019
ça met en évidence que certaines mesures
auraient nécessairement dû être prises
pour empêcher la pollution des mines
elle en est où cette procédure
aujourd'hui elle a été lancée fin
décembre elle a été lancée fin décembre
avec le dépôt de la plainte avait
conscience partie civile on attend la
désignation du juge d'instruction va lui
demander aussi d'identifier les dégâts
plus précisément les dégâts causés à
l'environnement dans le mois qui a suivi
on sait qu'il ya un certain nombre de
poissons plusieurs dizaines de poissons
qui ont été repêchés morts mais on sait
bien qu'on les a pas tous repêché même
ceux qui sont morts immédiatement
beaucoup en ont continué ce n'ont pas
été non pas été repêché il ya des
dizaines de ragondins un agneau aussi
qui est tombée on sait pas comment qui
est mort le malheureux et et les
batraciens manque de vision il ya un qui
sont estimés à plus long terme puisque
ça s'est passé au début du printemps
donc ça c'est dans les pas de vision sur
les conséquences en tout cas merci à
vous trois d'être passé en plateau on
suivra bien sûr la suite de cette
procédure dans nos prochaines éditions
allez dernière embarquement déjà pour
notre machine à remonter le temps toute
cette semaine nous revenons sur les
faits marquants de l'année 2019 dans les
yvelines focus ce soir sur les
événements qui ont marqué les mois
d'octobre à décembre avec marylène
iapichino cette fin d'année 2010 9 a
largement été marqué par les mouvements
sociaux cela n'était pas arrivé depuis
2001 les policiers se sont mobilisés
pour une marche de la colère à paris les
épinoy était du cortège forte
mobilisation également des agriculteurs
conditions de travail sentiment de
persécution ils ont bloqué les péages et
l'hérault divine oise pour même terminé
sur le périphérique parisien et les
hôpitaux ont réalisé plusieurs actions
pour dénoncer leurs conditions de
travail de plus en plus difficile avec
par exemple cette opération à l'hôpital
mignot symbolisant la mort de l'hôpital
enfin et surtout la grève illimitée
contre le projet de réforme des
retraites
elle a débuté le 5 décembre et un pacte
grandement les transports les cheminots
de versailles se montre particulièrement
déterminé la suite c'est la continuation
de la grève
son renforcement et la question de sa
généralisation à tous les secteurs et
puis ma foi s'il faut faire
la bûche de noël sur les piquets en
france le conflit est toujours actif en
ce début janvier une durée record une
dimension inter professionnelle
plusieurs actions locales et notamment
le 17 décembre
six cents manifestants se sont réunis à
versailles une réforme basée sur le
rapport du haut commissaire jean paul
delevoye
il est justement venu en débattre et
faire de la pédagogie à vélizy l'homme
d'état a depuis démissionné de ses
fonctions
nicole belloubet garde des sceaux a
rencontré les acteurs des quartiers de
reconquête républicaine attrape la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
frédéric vidal s'est rendu auprès des
étudiantes de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines sous la
thématique de la précarité étudiante
edouard philippe le premier ministre et
sa ministre du travail mme muriel
pénicaud ont lancé l'application mon
compte formation à guyancourt
enfin le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner a présenté son plan
anti communautariste au mur au début
décembre avant de revenir à la fin du
mois à magny les hameaux pour la
présentation du dispositif de
sécurisation de la nuit de la saint
sylvestre
mais l'événement qui a le plus concentré
de ministres dans le département c'est
malheureusement la santé du chapiteau de
chanteloup les vignes annonçant des
criminels sur un centre culturel
inauguré seulement un an auparavant
immédiatement la décision a été prise de
le reconstruire et pour cela les tailles
des collectivités locales ont assuré
leur soutien financier
vous savez quand on voit ça on se dit
mais ça va transformer durablement la
vie des gamins c'est à dire qu'il va y
va ce n'est plus rien ne se passe et ça
c'est pas possible
plus de 700 entreprises au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
quatrième convention d'affaires sky
business day a permis quête mille rendez
vous entre acteurs de l'économie du
territoire votées depuis 2010 est la
fusion des départements des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine n'est pas encore
effective
mais les travaux communs se multiplient
lagence d'insertion yvelinoise activity
a élargi son champ d'action aux hauts de
seine un portail internet commun aux
deux départements a été ouvert on est
plus fort à deux que tout seul
ce que nous voulons mettre en oeuvre
aussi bien travers la fusion qu'à
travers les progrès que nous faisons
administrativement techniquement dans
cette fusion celle inverse
c'est donc que c'est l'administration se
met au service de l'usager au service du
citoyen le syndicat mixte yvelines
numériques est devenue scène et les
numériques
les deux présidents de départements ont
même été auditionné sur ce projet de
fusion à l'assemblée nationale enfin
l'université des mairies des yvelines
accueilli aussi les maires des
hauts-de-seine pour la première fois le
mercredi 16 octobre 259 mer des yvelines
et 36 des hauts-de-seine se sont
retrouvés à port marly le mois de
novembre a marqué un anniversaire celui
des 30 ans de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
de nombreuses communes l'ont célébré par
différents ateliers sur le camp
militaire de satory le quatuor à cordes
de l'armée de terre a donné une série de
représentations pour la première fois
ouverte au public
enfin côté sport le son troisième open
de france de golf s'est tenue au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est le belge nicolas colsaerts qui
s'est imposé sur le green
plus de 6000 personnes par jour sont
venues y assister depuis lundi vous le
savez les vacances sont terminées mais
rassurez-vous pas les idées de sorties
avec moi plateau mélanie poquet bonsoir
ce week-end encore il ya de nombreuses
animations sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
pourquoi ne pas se laisser tenter par
une soirée punk à voisins-le-bretonneux
mais tu as assez investi la salle de la
tour alors ce samedi 11 janvier 4
groupes punk vont se partager la scène
des groupes locaux comme les poissons
noirs ou les monkeys the bollocks et le
coût de la soirée c'est la tête
d'affiche ce sont les washington dead
cats et un groupe majeur de la scène
alternative fondée en 1984
[Musique]
le concert débute à 20h c'est à la salle
de la tour de voisins-le-bretonneux et
l'équipe de meta sauce annonce déjà la
couleur
un bon gros concert punk qui va faire
mal aux oreilles du côté de plaisir
c'est un rendez vous à vivre à deux oui
à deux mais en famille l'association
pleasure à ce qu'on la promotion du
théâtre et du spectacle vivant propose
un stage alors pour y participer il faut
former un binôme parents enfants grands
parents enfants un nom comme temps comme
vous le voulez avec un enfant bien sûr
un dj gregory vous l'aurez compris c'est
de vivre à deux et ce dimanche 12
janvier vous ferez des petits jeux
théâtre où on va travailler le corps la
voix les émotions
l'espace scénique voilà un petit peu
tout ce qui tout ce qui fait les bases
les bases du théâtre c'est vraiment
l'idée de partager ensemble le temps
d'une journée un atelier alors on finira
par un petit goûter festif
l'histoire que voilà qu'on finisse comme
ça avec un petit débriefing entre nous
alors des inscriptions sont à prévoir
auprès de virgin et la présidente ce
stage peut aussi être l'occasion
pourquoi pas de découvrir une activité à
faire à la rentrée de septembre
merci mélanie est votre première
émission de l'année le 7-8 loisirs est à
retrouver ce soir sur tv 78 après ce
journal alors de la page municipal pour
terminer à montigny le bretonneux la
majorité sortante a lancé sa campagne ce
jeudi matin pour prendre la suite et du
maire jean-luc ourgaud élus en 2017 et
qui ne se représentera pas la liste
montigny ensemble sera conduite par l'ex
directeur de cabinet laurent 1 mais
requiert une candidature sans étiquette
mais avec une sensibilité centriste
marie daigne à pied finaux et jade bras
après 19 ans de service il a quitté son
poste de directeur de cabinet le 31
décembre dernier pour se lancer
pleinement dans cette campagne
laurens merckaert conduit la liste
montigny ensemble ici de la majorité
sortante
nous avons l'intention bien sûr de
préserver ce à quoi les gens sont très
attachés dans la ville c'est à dire un
cadre de vie privilégié des services
extrêmement important et aussi dans la
relation qu'il peut y avoir entre les
habitants et leurs élus une connexion
permanente transition écologique
sécurité une réhabilitation du
centre-ville imaginé avec les habitants
sont les grandes lignes du programme qui
sera dévoilé fin février avec les 39 nom
de la liste un groupe montigné ensemble
qui sera renouvelée à 50 %
on peut parler de continuité créatrice
voilà c'est à dire continuer à
travailler
comme on l'a toujours fait mais essayer
de faire en sorte aussi d'y apporter
tous les changements que nous estimons
nécessaire et ce toujours en étroite
collaboration avec nos habitants lorrain
merckaert se présente sans étiquette
mais de sensibilité centriste au sein
d'un groupe ouvert
je n'ai pas sollicité de soutien en
revanche si les parties souhaitent des
partis républicains bien sûr souhaite
m'apporter leur soutien je le prendrai
avec plaisir et évidemment je le ferais
figurait sur la fiche je pense qu'il
faut être dire les choses comme elles
sont vis-à-vis des habitants première
réunion publique pour cette liste le 15
janvier à la salle jacques-brel lésigny
montants ont déjà commencé à recevoir le
courrier de candidature dans leur boîte
aux lettres les tractages commenceront
le premier week-end de février elle sera
candidate à la derrière cette fois ci
pour un mandat complet bonsoir nelly du
tube maire sortant de communistes vous
conduirez la liste la verrière en commun
on rappelle que vous avez pris la suite
d'un arrachage en cours de mandat de
maire qui était maire depuis 2012 et qui
a démissionné en 2016 pour raisons de
santé
pourquoi être candidat de cette fois ci
pour un mandat complet bien parce que je
pense qu'on a depuis les quatre ans que
je suis là j'ai j'ai suivi le programme
de 2014
je les mener à bien au bout
on a pris nos marques on a fait l'équipe
et moir
on a rénové un certain nombre
d'équipements sur la ville on a eu
beaucoup de projets il ya l'anru qui est
repartie ya la zac gare bécane qui
repart et des projets plus sociaux j'ai
envie de dire
et donc je j'ai beaucoup de projets dans
la tête des choses c'est bien sûr au
service des verriers roi donc je repars
de jeter des choses encore à faire et
vous le disiez ce qui avait été promis
dans cette mandature depuis 2014 a été
réalisée dans la grande majorité bien
sûr bien sûr donc la crèche en faisait
partie
elle va avoir les premiers coups de
pioche autour du mois de mars avril
donc voilà
il ya des choses en plus puisque la
rénovation des espaces du parc n'était
pas prévu mais on a on a saisi
l'occasion que nous tendait le
département
l'anru était mal parti on l'a remis sur
les rails
donc oui oui on a on a fait beaucoup je
pense qu'on n'a pas à rougir de notre du
mandat qu'on a qu'on a effectués jeu
c'est vrai que je suis arrivé en milieu
de mandat je pense pont il a fallu un
petit temps de l'adaptation
mais je suis bien dans cette fonction
maintenant et je vous dis on a pleins
pleins d'idées à défendre dans le dans
la perspective d'améliorer la vie de
tous les jours des verriers roi alors la
verrière c'est une ville communiste
depuis les années 1970
et si une ville où la gauche partira dit
viser pour ces élections aux élus de la
majorité dont quatre adjoints sont
menées par jean-yves blé ils vont
également conduire une liste ils avaient
pris leurs distances avec vous il ya un
an dénonçant à l'époque un manque de
concertation
est ce que ça vous a fait douter dans
votre envie de vous présenter ce cette
scission pas du tout pas du tout
le procès qui m'est fait deux
d'un manque de concertation j'avoue ne
pas trop le comprendre les concertations
des a toujours mené même plus de
réunions que tout seul qu'on doive avoir
lieu
l'instant fin puisqu'il ya eu il ya eu
des débats autour de la crèche eux
je regardais monsieur blé la dernière
fois lui même dit qu'il sait c'est lui
qui a eu l'idée de la mettre à la pmi
oui ben y avait plusieurs y avait
plusieurs endroits à la m j'ai écouté on
a voté on était à l'unanimité moins deux
voix sur sur l'emplacement
tout allait bien et dans ce coup quelque
chose des rails
bon je vais laisser la responsabilité à
chacun chacun sa façon de voir les
choses que ça veut dire que tu
qu'aujourd'hui un risque d'alternance
que finalement la gauche perde la
verrière non non vous yao fais pas ça
qui fait la lotion parce que ce n'est
qu'en même temps moi ça ne parle pas de
ce n'est pas moi qui fais semer la
division du coup est ce qu'il ya une
subtilité de la réconciliation ou c'est
pas à l'ordre du jour
je n'ai jamais demandé aux gens de
partir je l'aurais même proposé de
rester et jusqu'à aujourd'hui alors que
[Musique]
le monsieur blé etc quand les anciens
élus enfin les élus d'aujourd'hui font
une liste ils sont toujours adjoint je
les ai pas je n'aurai pas enlever leur
mandat mais du coup quid de votre liste
est ce qu'elle est complète
aujourd'hui elle est complète vous avez
trouvé l'ensemble de vos colistiers ce
que vous la liste est complète g
alors vous allez me demander mais j'ai
le soutien de mon parti du de bajus
quand je vais vous le demander dans les
séries tu sentais bien et c'est normal
non j'ai le soutien de ma section de mon
département et du national il ya je n'ai
aucun souci de ce côté là et à côté de
ça mon sujet n'est pas tant ça que
d'avoir une liste qui représente
les habitants de la verrière l'alleud la
grande grande grande majorité de son
quartier nulle part mais on partage on
partage des valeurs on partage la notion
du service public la notion du bien
commun et c'est ça qui privilégie les
privilégiés dans cette liste mais c'est
d'associer peut-être les habitants à
votre démarche vous avez souhaité
construire votre programme avec les
verriers roi il ya des ateliers qui ont
été organisées depuis octobre pourquoi
cette démarche
du coup pas parce que j'aime il semble
que pour faire un programme qui
correspond aux habitants il vaut
peut-être mieux les écouter d'abord voir
ou où malgré malgré tout ce qu'on a fait
et où ça à pêcher quand même parce que
bon on n'est pas non plus à 100 % de ce
qu'on a fait qu'est ce qui pour eux est
important qu est-ce qui voudrait changer
en priorité donc il faut d'abord
peut-être un peu écouté les gens avant
de leur proposer d un programme qui
correspond quoi ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'est pas encore
prêt ou dans les grandes lignes en tout
cas on a en a effectivement récolter les
doléances j'ai envie de dire de des
verriers roi et avec ça on est en train
de travailler sur un programme qui
correspondent à la teneur de ce qu'on a
eue avec qu est ce qui ressort des
priorités justement des verriers roisel
identifie des courses et l'éducation
l'éducation des enfants
la formation des jeunes des 16-25
l'emploi bien sûr well ailleurs il ya 16
% de chômage ça c'est une thématique il
est qui les inquiète si ben ils ont
raison quand même
je comprends qu'avec 16 % de chômage ya
un souci quand même on a un quartier qui
est en dessous du seuil de pauvreté et
40 % des gens sont en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté
c'est normal que les parents
s'inquiètent de l'avenir de leurs
enfants et demande une aide de ce côté
là alors l'aide est l'escalet puisque on
est une commune on n'est ni une
entreprise ni l'éducation nationale mais
je peux pas m'en parler
on peut aider il ya plein de choses à
faire on est en train d'en 2
de m d'expérimenter peut-être des choses
dans le programme qu'on va qu'on va
sortir un mot vous parler de la
rénovation urbaine justement cette
rénovation urbaine du bois de l'étang
vous souhaitez vous plutôt une
réhabilitation puis puis sans
destruction par une réhabilitation
plutôt qu'une destruction c'est ça alors
l'anru en là on a savez bien qu'enfin il
ya eu un moment très très compliqué il
ya quelques années
quand j'ai repris les discussions mon
grand souci était d'apaiser les choses
déjà et après de recommencer à discuter
avec la population du bois de l'étang
on a eu des comités de vie et de
voisinage ça fait déjà quasiment deux
ans qu'on en a à peu près tous les mois
et demi deux 2 mois on a recommencé à
discuter dans la confiance revient petit
à petit et il y avait cette question
centrale de la démolition
au bout d'un moment il m'a semblé
important de prendre position parce
qu'autrement on restait dans du fou et
on n'arrivait pas en sortir
donc j'ai pris position contre les
démolitions plusieurs points mais et g
le conseil municipal a voté
majoritairement contre les démolitions
une question car vous êtes aussi vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
en charge de l'économie sociale et
solidaire voilà j'avais perdu ma fiche
est ce que le travail mené avec
l'agglomération est satisfaisant
aujourd'hui vous souhaitez renforcer
davantage les liens je pense que de ce
côté là on peut faire beaucoup beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus et notamment mené des
projets il ya le doublement de la
villedieu qui est un projet qui pourrait
arriver
alors ça c'est
ce serait bien ce serait bien le matin
tout est engorgé de part et d'autre du
pont
dans la transversale tout pareil là il
ya vraiment de quoi réfléchir à une
meilleure
à être desservie parce qu'il ya toute la
zone industrielle de trappes elancourt
qui est là là il ya vraiment une
réflexion à avoir
oui dernière chose pardon est ce que
vous avez un prochain rendez vous avec
les habitants ah oui on a d'abord les
voeux puisque mes voeux sont ouverts à
toute la population est en général elle
répond bien présente
et puis le 31 décembre c'est la liste la
verrière en commun qui qui appelle les
gens à venir partager une galette est
aussi 31 janvier vous avez dit 31
décembre ce sera d'argenlieu 10 31
rendez vous le 21 janvier 31 janvier
merci où on va entre autres présenté nos
mots nos candidats merci nelly du maire
sortant communiste de la dernière tête
de liste de la verrière en commun pour
ces prochaines élections municipales et
en face de vous je précise il y aura
jean yves blé nicolas dainville et
également girard claude morfin qui
conduira une liste la verrière citoyenne
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]